salut aujourd'hui nous sommes mercredi
c'est le jour de l'astuce de la semaine
de l'astuce du mentalist je vais vous
parler du vha cox qui va vous permettre
de mieux communiquer d'être meilleur
communicant vous parler avec quelqu'un
en face à face le back up faut savoir
deux choses dessus la première chose
c'est que c'est pas un gros mot on a le
droit de dire wacogne la deuxième chose
c'est que ça permet d'être en face sur
le canal de son interlocuteur un petit
peu comme si vous étiez de la même tribu
et que vous parliez avec les mêmes codes
vous connaissez forcément à l'école de
langage sociaux les codes de langage
générationnel il existe aussi un code
universel on appelle ça le van gogh
c'est le canal principal d'une personne
d'accord c'est à dire visuelle auditive
kinesthésique olfactif et goûts toutes
les personnes quelles qu'elles soient
navigue sur ces cinq canaux de
communication et lorsqu'elle parle avec
quelqu'un moi le premier vous aussi les
personnes que vous rencontrez dans votre
vie tout le monde mais on a tous une
préférence pour un canal principal en
général on va plutôt le chercher dans le
vague visuel auditif ou knesset hésiter
d'une manière encore plus générale on va
le chercher dans le visuel ou dans
l'auditif c'est un savoir qui est très
utile en pnl en hypnose on utilise aussi
dans d'autres choses comme dans le
marketing dans la vente
ce qu'il ya de vraiment formidable avec
ça c'est que ça permet de se connecter à
l'autre en étant un peu sur la même
longueur d'onde sur la même fréquence
pour détecter le canal d'une personne il
va falloir je l'écouté va falloir
l'écouté attentivement il va falloir
aussi regarder où vont un petit peu
c'est user je reviens pas sur tout ce
qui est mouvements oculaires pour ça
vous pouvez regarder ma vidéo sur le
mensonge où j'explique sa plus longue en
écoutant une personne parle et vous
allez avoir plein d'indicés sur quel est
son canal principal si la personne
utilise des mots plutôt visuel comme
regarder voir montrer ou alors des
caractéristiques visuelles par exemple
aujourd'hui il fait très beau moi j'ai
envie de dire que c'est une journée très
lumineuse ça c'est vraiment une phrase
de visuels les visuels vont utiliser
logiquement des descriptions images et
des choses avec les formes avec les
couleurs avec les verbes qui sont en
rapport avec le regard avec les yeux
avec le fait de voir un outil va
utiliser des verres comme entendre
parler crier des nuances aussi de son
fort faible et ça se retrouve également
dans ses tics verbaux écoute il fait
beau on pourrait sortir dans cette
phrase-là écoute il fait bon pourrait
sortir ya assez peu d'indications sur le
kinesthésique où le visuel par contre ça
commence par écoute alors qu'un visuel
aurait peut-être dire regarde
kinesthésique c'est encore différent
c'est tout ce qui est ressenti qui soit
émotionnelle où qu'ils soient physiques
il a donc utilisé des mots de sensations
comme lourds-légers sentir ressentir
pour le temps qu'il fait il parlerait
plutôt du fait qu'il fait chaud
aujourd'hui que c'est à gré
s'il a quelque chose qui te gêne chez
quelqu'un il va dire commence vraiment à
me gratter en ce moment alors qu'un
visuel va dire tu vas voir comment je
vais lui répondre
alors qu'un audit heavy rain en mettant
temps quand il parle comme souvent
lorsque je vous explique
il ya des contradicteurs à cette théorie
ses contradicteurs nous explique ya pas
de fondement à tous ce raisonnement là
toute cette logique
pour ma part je m'en sers beaucoup dans
ma manière de communiquer avec l'autre
vous avez sûrement ce vécu ce moment où
vous assister à deux personnes qui
disent la même chose pas avec les mêmes
mots elles se comprennent pas et elle
s'engage alors que vous vous êtes
observateur et vous apercevez qu'elles
disent la même chose dans ces cas là
c'est juste qu'ils sont pas branchés du
tout sur le même mode de communication
vous pouvez vous en servir sur des
entretiens d'embauché à des examens
oraux vous avez à passer il suffit en
quelques mots un petit peu de discuter
avec la personne en face de vous de
regarder aussi le regard rappelez vous
la vidéo dont je vous ai parlé en début
détectée également votre canal principal
le mien et moi je suis un visuel c'est
clair et net
d'ailleurs dans c'est clair et net il ya
encore une image efforcez-vous comme ça
de faire ce travail
en plus ça va vous permettre de mieux
écouter l'autre et de mieux communiquer
si vous connaissiez pas tout ça je suis
ravi de l'avoir fait découvrir vous
poème le set faire savoir en laissant un
petit pouce en l'air
si vous connaissiez déjà ça vous fera
une piqûre de rappel et ça aussi on aime
le faire savoir mais là c'est différent
il faudrait plutôt laissé inchangé le
qui bat fort parce qu'apparemment je le
crier trop dimanche n'a passé le premier
tiers de mon défi de cette année c'est à
dire que dimanche on a fait la 122e
vidéo aujourd'hui c'est la 125e vidéo
comme j'ai déjà fait un tiers de l'année
une vidéo par jour pendant un tiers de
l'année
c'est un peu ours c'est beaucoup grâce à
vous merci d'être là merci beaucoup en
fait d'ailleurs si vous n'êtes pas
abonné vous pouvez le faire en cliquant
sur le petit logo qui en eau dans la
vidéo numéro 100 ge annoncé le défi du
prochain objectif à 50 mille abonnés
vous laisse regarder la vidéo numéro 100
si vous êtes au courant et merci
beaucoup d'être là le mental voc cette
vidéo par jour pendant un an donc rendez
vous demain à 17 heures pour le prochain
mandat le blog ciao